so i spoke about or maybe actually i
think
prague was the fourth
youngest gm of all time and cinderella
was the third youngest
but now i'm playing gakesh from india
who i think was the second youngest gm
and he's still
only i think 15 and
obviously extremely talented as well so
i'm expecting another
tough game here yeah no more of this
london stuff
i'm going to give him a banco gambit
because why not
wouldn't generally recommend this gambit
though
it has the unfortunate side effect of
losing a pawn
but it's fine oh that's a problem with
castling
that's the problem with castling yeah
okay
but you can play another way you can
play with bishop f5 i think
uh yeah i think this is considered to be
decent
bishop g4 he's playing fast at least
but i think forcing f3 and e4 is a
pretty big big win for me so now i have
ideas of
uh of um knight before
bishop a6 and also knight d7
and he's weak in both of these
diagonals now a3
i think i'm just going to jump in still
and why did i jump in
because i'm a [ __ ] that's why okay
we'll go back
okay that was really dumb that was
really really dumb
but it's fine though i still have some
typical blanket gambit pressure
with a solid structure and a couple of
half open lines
now i went bishop a6
and rook b8
bishop f1 huh i think i'll grab that one
we'll give a check
and this is starting to look pretty
promising for me
i think bishop f1 was was not good
probably needed to do something a little
bit more circumspect there
okay let's take on c3
i think i'm happy to play an ending here
takes an a6
take and then take an a3 winning the
pawn back with i think
some initiative
bc3 immediately i don't want to take an
e2 and bring his king
closer to the center and i think i'll
just keep the
keep the queen son and i think with the
structure
that we have um
he's uh his king is gonna be
less safe than than mine but
yeah anyway he decides to not to trade
queens
i think in both cases he was he was
worse
uh but i think trading may have been the
lesser evil since it feels like now
i'm pretty much just invading
probably needs this one but i at least
have knight g4
but also knight d3 looks good
queen c3 gradually
bringing my troops closer and
eventually i should start picking up
some material
king h3 seems natural to escape but
i think i'll just start grabbing now
fred if it takes i have rookie too
and i'm also threatening knight f4 now
winning the queen
now i got queen c2 it's only tries maybe
f5 but i got knight e5 covering
everything
the other knight can go to eight and
then to f6 so it should be very safe
e5 i'll just grab
and i think his position is absolutely
hopeless here
f5 i can take an e3 but let's just grab
as much as possible right
i like this game apart from that knight
before knight f6
uh nonsense i think uh it's pretty
instructive and really
the the most you can hope for in a in a
banker gambit game
where you just break through on the
on the on the queen side and then you
win
because your king is is safer and your
pawn structure is more solid